maybe it's been a while since you felt
like you've had your mojo maybe you
remember times in the past maybe several
years ago where you actually felt
incredible a lot more incredible than
you do now i feel like all of us at some
point in our lives have had little
checkpoints where we remember feeling
incredible either we were in a flow
state where we were uninhibited by our
social anxiety or maybe times where you
just felt energetic enthusiastic about
life and motivated to actually take
constructive action in my life i feel
like i have finally entered a period
where i feel good like most days i feel
quite good and that's sort of foreign to
me you know i'm very prone to negative
emotion i get into my head a lot and
depression runs deep in my family so i
pay special attention to the actions
that i do throughout the day and how
that affects my mental health and
recently i've started doing a few things
that have really helped me feel better
and i live my life with more energy more
enthusiasm towards my work my personal
life and overall it just feels better to
feel this way so hopefully through this
video if you guys are going through a
rough time and you want to enter into a
period of your life where you just feel
better on average you're more
enthusiastic to wake up in the morning
and you want to feel like you have your
mojo back then hopefully some of the
things that i've started doing can help
you as well feel free to experiment take
it or leave it but this is what i've
been doing to make me feel really good
so number one is very simple every
single morning i've been waking up at
the same time every single day and
immediately i walk outside and i smell
the fresh air and bonus points if the
sun is shining and you see a little bird
flying by and let the hot sun beat down
on your pale face i'm talking about me
of course i have no melanin in my skin
whatsoever and if i want to take this
one step further i'll actually go for a
walk before i have my coffee i'll put on
my running shoes and i'll go for a walk
around the block and while this practice
may sound overly simple it's kind of a
game changer for me because i actually
feel like endorphins are rushing through
my body my brain is getting flushed with
positive neurochemicals it also gives me
a little window of time to not look at
my phone and start thinking of the
things that i can accomplish today i can
think of the people in my life that i
want to spend time with i can think of
the person that i want to be and i can
be grateful for a fresh start a new
opportunity to restore order and
contribute to the world and make a
difference hopefully and this might
sound super cheesy to you i mean it
would for me if i didn't start going on
these morning walks because when you're
cooped up in your house all day and you
immediately jump on the internet it's
hard to have cheesy wholesome thoughts
like this and when someone says
something like this to you you might say
oh that sounds overly disney being
thankful for a fresh start but honestly
stepping outside of your house and
getting off the internet will do that to
you you will actually start to have
positive thoughts again so first thing
in the morning when you wake up don't go
on your phone don't check twitter walk
outside of your room put on some runners
go walk out your front door you don't
even need to put on shoes just walk out
your front door fill your lungs with
that fresh clean air look up at the sun
but not too long or you'll go blind and
just take a few seconds to be thankful
for a fresh start and a new day that
will set the tone for the entire rest of
the day and you will never regret doing
that and that leads very well into the
next thing that i've been doing which is
intentionally doing things and going
places that elevate my mood so this one
sounds really obvious but i actually
don't think it is because so often in
our lives we will do the same things
every single day we'll go to work we'll
come home we'll sit on the computer we
tend to do the things that we've always
done and we slowly and slowly and slowly
might become more cynical we might start
to think that there's no point you know
what's the point of doing the same thing
every single day waking up and working
for the same boss and the same job that
you don't like but every once in a while
your sister might text you and say hey
do you want to go for a walk on the
beach shore and you usually say no
because you're super busy but this one
time you're like okay sure let's do it i
haven't hung out with my sister in a
long time so you go for a walk on the
beach and you look around and you say
holy smokes the world isn't so bad the
sounds of the seagulls chirping in the
air i don't know if seagulls chirp they
kind of like squawk you know people are
walking their dog this attractive couple
is on a very awkward first date and it's
fun to people watch them and you're
getting moving the blood is flowing and
all of a sudden this new experience
gives you a fresh perspective and it
elevates your mood but it's so funny
because everyone can kind of relate to
the story but then they go back to doing
the same thing that they've always done
slowly becoming more cynical until they
reach a breaking point and they do that
kind of thing again but why not
implement the things that make you feel
good regularly into your life why not
have a weekly schedule of going for a
walk on the beachfront with your sister
why not actually go to that book group
on friday filled with smiling faces and
attractive people of your same age and
this is going to be very different for
everybody you know what makes me feel
good might not necessarily make you feel
good you know the things that kind of
break up that pattern and make you kind
of excited to be alive again make an
effort to make that thing a regular part
of your life because those things are
the types of things that make life worth
living so try to really evaluate in your
life what are the things that make you
feel inspired invigorated refreshed and
optimistic i don't know what that is for
you but if there is something that comes
to mind maybe it's something that you
haven't done in a long time make an
effort to make that a regular thing in
your life it will give your better
thoughts your more optimistic viewpoint
some more airtime and over the course of
days and weeks and months and years
you'll find that giving your more
optimistic tendencies more airtime will
really benefit your mental health in the
long run okay so the third thing that
i've been doing that has really helped
me feel incredible is that i've started
to put more effort into my appearance so
this is probably going to be the most
controversial one on this list i feel
like a lot of self-improvement advice
out there including some i've probably
given as well has really emphasized the
point that external circumstances won't
necessarily make you happier you know if
you buy a new car you get a fancy house
you get a cool dog that you know people
compliment you on you know these things
won't make you a better person
especially if the desire to attain these
material possessions comes from a place
of insecurity you know if you're feeling
really bad about yourself like you have
really low self-esteem and low
self-worth then buying a new shirt and
spending a bunch of money on a new
iphone probably isn't gonna help you
it'll just distract you for like a day i
think everyone knows this but i think
there also is something to be said about
dressing in a way and presenting
yourself to the world in a more
dignified way in a way that reflects
your inherent dignity and worth as a
person so the clothing choices that you
have and the fact that you cut your hair
and trim your nails isn't necessarily
what makes you have value as a person
but it sure as hell reflects it and as
we've talked about in previous videos
your subconscious is very perceptive
it's constantly evaluating other people
and making judgment calls about them but
it's also doing the same thing to you so
when you wear clothes that don't fit if
you wear clothes that are extremely kind
of drab and uninspiring you're not
showering you're not trimming your beard
or cutting your hair your subconscious
is picking up on these things it is
evaluating your appearance and making a
judgment call of your self-worth based
on that so there's almost no avoiding it
it's an automatic mechanism and it's
almost like a chicken or the egg thing
because
by getting a fresh haircut buy buying
nice clothes that fit you and by
showering and taking care of yourself
and appearing well in the world and
orderly in the world your subconscious
does look at that and it will feel
better about your self-worth obviously
this isn't a permanent solution but it
all contributes to this feeling of
dignity man it really sounds like i'm
just rationalizing the fact that i got
some new drip recently i don't know if
you need to do this much thinking before
buying new clothes but hopefully you can
see where i'm coming from i do really
believe
that if you're more proud of the clothes
that you put on the haircut that you
have or the lack of hair and just
keeping [ __ ] tight against your head i
do feel like you'll go about the world
in a more confident way it's kind of
like making your bed in the morning and
you can't just restore order to the
whole kingdom by cleaning the foyer but
cleaning the foyer does reflect the fact
that you're an orderly kingdom or that
you run an orderly kingdom or whatever i
don't know i'm bad at allegories today
but i feel great okay so the fourth
thing is that i've been keeping a list
to restore order so in the notes app of
my phone i keep this list called things
in order and i have a giant inventory of
all of the main domains of my life that
i could be restoring order to it starts
with my physical surroundings is my
bedroom clean is the office clean the
top floor the main floor the basement
how about my finances where am i at with
that my habits how are those you know my
social life my spiritual life i really
flesh out each category of my life and
what criteria i would have in order for
me to consider that domain relatively
orderly so this might seem kind of
obsessive and i feel like there's a
self-improvement philosophy that is
making its way through the internet that
would be tempted a philosophy that would
be tempted philosophy philosophies don't
get tempted but if you hold this
philosophy you might be tempted to say
that's self-obsessive you're setting
yourself up for misery because that's
conditional happiness you have a big
criteria of things and achievements that
you have to hit before you can feel
totally satisfied in life but i think
that's completely bs because the world
is always and constantly in a state of
decay if you leave things alone things
always get worse and disintegrate rather
than stay the same some might call it
entropy some may call it the destructive
nature of time but that's just the way
the world works if you neglect taking
care of your teeth your teeth will rot
right out of your skull if you don't
clean your kitchen regularly and do the
dishes a stench will start to develop
and you will attract pests no matter how
you spin it if you're not constantly
maintaining order if you don't live your
life in a mode of being that is
constructive then time will naturally
destruct but there's a silver lining to
all this it's not so hamster wheely and
fatalistic and that silver lining is
that it actually feels good to restore
order in your life so when you have this
thorough list of things that you have to
restore order in your life to check
those boxes feels good on the inside it
makes you feel proud of the existence
that you're living when you put your
head on your pillow at night you can say
i put my time to good use today and
without that direction in life without
that game plan of like what you're
actually doing in the present moment and
what you're working towards then by
definition you're directionless which is
kind of synonymous with meaninglessness
directionless meaningless either way
it's not good so one of the most
optimistic things that i've done
recently by far is to make this thorough
list and every single day i try to check
a box or check a fraction of a box and
just take inventory of all the things in
my life that i have autonomy over all
the things that i can contribute to and
it helps me feel like i'm the master of
my fate the ironic thing is i'm actually
kind of tired i didn't get a lot of
sleep last night so if my eyes are puffy
and i look kind of miserable
it kind of totally goes against this
whole message you might be watching this
video be like joey says he's okay but he
doesn't look okay
but i feel great so the final thing on
this list is a no-brainer thing but it
absolutely has to be covered because
it's probably the most important thing
you've just heard it a million times
before number five is that i stopped
being an absolute dum-dum with my health
there's no getting around the fact that
when you start working out when you
start being active and you get the blood
pumping and the iron uh when you start
juicing no don't juice there's
absolutely no getting around the fact
that when you start going for runs you
start getting exercise you feel like a
greek god when you drink enough water
you feel like poseidon the monotonous
things in life don't feel so
drab and absolutely agonizing to get
through it's because you actually have
the mental energy to get through them so
on average save for last night obviously
i've been getting way more sleep i've
been drinking more water i've been
hitting my very specific supplement
stack which i'll go over right at the
end here i've been working out i've been
doing more cardio i've been going
outside for walks and taking care of my
health like this is the cornerstone of
my mental health you know your physical
health and your mental health are so
intimately linked in ways that are
beyond our understanding so let's talk
about my supplement stack that's what
everyone's probably dying to know um i
kind of covered it in a previous video
but i've kind of modified it so i am not
advocating or prescribing anything to
you i'm just telling you what i take
always consult your medical professional
uh of choice your favorite one on what
you should be putting into your body and
i'm not a doctor i'm just a dude but
this is what i have every single morning
and it makes me feel great all right so
my current supplement stack is vitamin d
which i have uh in oil form with a olive
oil carrier so it's vitamin d3 and k2 i
have 500 milligrams of vitamin c which
keeps me healthy during these viral
times i take five milligrams of creatine
with water and that is actually one of
the only proven nootropics that
apparently contributes to short-term
memory which is actually really
interesting because usually it's just
used for bodybuilding and going to the
gym and for athletes but not only does
it help with your physical energy but
also your mental energy and short-term
memory which is crazy i also am a big
fan of maca i personally find that it
gives me more energy apparently it
boosts libido too
so the final component of my supplement
stack is actually using a product which
is also the sponsor of today's video but
i've been using them for years way
before they were a sponsor of this video
and i actually reached out to them
saying please sponsor my stuff i'm
basically a walking ad for you anyways
so i might as well just further
evangelize in my video and then you can
just pay me to do that instead of me
doing it for free all the time a big
thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video there's a very
good reason why ag-1 by athletic greens
is my main supplement it's because
there's basically no competing with the
amount of nutrients that's in one scoop
of this stuff there's 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens in one
convenient daily serving ag-1 supports
your energy focus gut health digestion
immunity system and mental clarity
without the need to take multiple
products or pills athletic greens uses
these whole foods and these natural
sources and condenses them down to this
single scoop which you add to water you
shake it up and you drink it and
compared to so many different health
drinks and greens powders that i've
tried throughout my long history of
trying different nootropics and trying
to optimize my health this stuff by far
tastes the best so it's just a very
pleasant way to start my morning with
the confidence that i'm giving my body
all the tools that it needs
nutritionally to tackle the day with
energy so if you're interested in
joining me in this very simple health
optimization habit that i've been
partaking in for over two years now then
use my link in the description below and
you'll actually get a year's supply of
the vitamin d and k2 complex that i have
every single morning as well as five
ag-1 travel packs with your first
purchase so once again if you're
interested in taking advantage of this
incredible offer and getting a year's
supply of vitamin d3 and k2 plus 5 ag-1
travel packs with your first purchase
then click my link in the description
below optimize your health feel
invigorated and powerful and as usual
have a great time if you like this video
make sure that you hit like if you hit
the like button then it actually the
algorithm goes oh this is a good video i
will shove this guy's bald head into
other people's homepages helping them
out which also helps me out so it's a
win-win for everybody involved so make
sure you actually click the button
because i want you to if you're lurking
here consider subscribing and hitting
that note don't hit the bell icon we
don't need any more needless
notifications in your life yeah just
consider subscribing it just looks good
on paper and check out the second
channel there's a lot of fun stuff on
there some family vlogs of mine if you
want to get to know me better there's
some q a videos and there's gonna be a
lot of fun stuff potentially even a
podcast popping up on there pretty soon
and if you're on instagram anyways which
you probably shouldn't be because it's
cancerous and um brutal but if you uh
don't follow my advice and you still go
on instagram then you might as well
follow our instagram because it's
probably slightly less of a waste of
time than other people's instagram i
don't know that's a bad pitch we we just
need more followers i think but if you
don't feel like following it don't
follow it um cool but other than that
that is all for today thank you so much
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video